democrats take georgia's senate seats
and with it unified control of the
american government
republicans focus on a last-gasp effort
to stave off certified electoral college
results
and the media lie about a police
shooting again i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from prying eyes at
expressvpn.com
ben well we'll get to the utter and
total screwing of the republic
in just one second first let me tell you
that if it feels like the walls are
closing in if it feels like perhaps
now might be an excellent time to
diversify out of the stock market
considering the tax increases and
regulatory increases that are in store
considering what is about to besiege the
republic well you might want to
diversify just a little bit into
precious metals and this is where my
friends
over at birch gold come in with the
democrats now controlling the house
and the senate and the presidency well
you can expect that the dollar is going
to be devalued you can expect that we're
going to get increased taxes
you can expect a slower than expected
recovery it's going to be good times all
around
but at least you can hedge against all
of those by buying into some precious
metals right now birch gold group it's
the premiere precious metals ira company
in america with an a plus better
business bureau rating countless
five-star reviews thousands of satisfied
customers
birch gold can help you move an eligible
ira or 401k
into an ira backed by gold and silver
there's a tidal wave of inflation coming
get ready
gold would be your hedge text ben 247
for your free information kit on
precious metals ira or speak with a
birch gold representative today
time is running out you can protect your
savings right now text ben
to 47 47 47 so
yep things suck all the way around so
republicans had two extraordinarily
winnable races in georgia
last night they proceeded to apparently
lose both so
raphael warnock who is a marxist radical
who hates the american founding believes
that america is inherently racist
who has praised fidel castro jeremiah
wright and lewis farrakhan in no
particular order
is going to take a seat in the united
states senate he actually was the
candidate who performed the best in
georgia last night meanwhile
on the other side john ossoff appears
that he will beat david perdue
in that runoff race purdue had beat
ossoff by some 80 000 votes
in the original november election and
now assaf appears to have outperformed
purdue it's within margin of error which
means that there will be a recount but
again the margin of loss for purdue
looks to be in the tens of thousands of
votes it is not in the hundreds of votes
so it is highly unlikely
that that race shifts in the direction
of the republicans
so let's start with what this means
before we get to the analysis of why
this happened in the first place
and i think we all have some indicators
as to why this happened in the first
place the stats on this are pretty good
let's talk about what this means for the
republic
so obviously joe biden now has unified
control of the government
joe biden will be inaugurated on january
20th
and the senate democrats led by chuck
schumer will be in charge of the senate
and nancy pelosi will be the speaker of
the house and the democrats
will have the power to do pretty much
anything they want now there are some
pretty significant limits on that powers
i'll explain in just a moment
but this was the whole pitch guys this
is why georgia mattered
is why george madden the reason that
georgia mattered the reason this was the
most important election of this year
okay was more important than the
presidential what just happened in
georgia
it was because the shift after the
presidential it meant that there was
still the opportunity for republicans to
be able to stymie
whatever insanity democrats had coming
down the line now that is likely off the
table
in some pretty significant ways and the
election last night was extremely
important
not just because of what is happening
right now but also because of what's
going down in the future
if you look at the status of the 2022
race
races for example if you look forward a
couple of years what you will see
is that the republicans are in quite a
bit of trouble in the near future
the 2022 senate map for example shows
the democrats will be
in defense in georgia arizona nevada and
new hampshire
biden won new hampshire he won nevada he
won arizona
and he won georgia okay so they're only
on defense
in states that biden won okay and that
are newly moving to
to toward the purple slash blue right
particularly georgia and arizona are the
shockers there
republicans will be on defense in the
senate in 2022
in pennsylvania wisconsin north carolina
florida and iowa
okay that means at least three of those
seats are are in serious danger right
pennsylvania
is increasingly a blue state wisconsin
is increasingly a blue state
north carolina is sort of in the middle
florida has moved red iowa has moved red
okay that means that there is a
significant likelihood that democrats
actually pick up
senate seats in 2022 barring some sort
of cataclysmic circumstance that's why
this mattered so awful much okay
typically
one party control of the entire american
government does not last for very long
in fact the last three times that it has
happened for democrats
within two years one party control has
faded away it has dissipated and it's
very likely that that could happen for
example in the house of representatives
as opposed to the senate
so in two years republicans could have a
real good year in the house that are
only
i believe nine seats short of a house
majority right now in the house of
representatives
so it's quite possible that republicans
take back the house in a couple of years
but we are in for a
couple of years of serious hurt that was
the pitch okay the original pitch here
should have been in georgia if you want
to stop joe biden
if you want joe biden not to have
unified control of the government you
need to elect republicans
in these races the problem is
and there are some problems here that a
lot of republicans
still think that donald trump is going
to be president on january 21st and so
it made it very difficult for purdue or
leffler to even make the argument they
needed to make
they're sort of half making it but
they're afraid of ticking off a lot of
their own base members who had been told
falsely that trump is still going to be
president january 21st he has not there
is no pathway for him
as we've discussed there's no legal
pathway for him and what happens today
in the senate
is for show it is not a real legal
pathway for him
okay so lefleur and purdue should have
been campaigning on you want to stop joe
biden from utterly controlling the
american government you need to elect us
they couldn't
that was taken off the table okay so
what does that mean it now means that
the democrats are going to
control all three branches of government
and the gridlock will be broken joe
biden was saying this himself here is
joe biden before the election saying
that if you elect warnock and if you
elect ossoff
either if you like both of them then uh
we can end this gridlock and we can move
forward with my
progressive agenda he is pledging that
he's going to be the most progressive
president since fdr so good luck with
that
the power is literally in your hands
by electing john and a reverend you can
break the gridlock
that has gripped washington and this
nation
with their votes in the senate we'll be
able to make the progress we need to
make on jobs
on health care on justice on the
environment and so many important things
okay so this was the pitch right and the
counter pitch was you got to stop that
guy from doing all of this
the problem was trump kept arguing that
he was going to be able to
to change the results of the certified
electoral college votes
and thus many republicans stayed home i
mean the data that we have
show that the people who are least
likely to show up
in this georgia runoff elections in
these runoff elections the people least
likely to show up
or people who are in rural red counties
right
exactly the area where trump usually
shows the strongest because
trump both was not on the ballot for the
republicans and he was also telling
people
that if you don't show up i'll still
probably be president on january 21st so
it really
is not that big of a deal he went down
there and he campaigned and good for him
he should have campaigned but the
problem was he was also running ads in
the last week of the election
saying things like the election in
georgia was so screwed
you can't trust kemp you can't trust
raffensberger you can't trust any of the
republicans in the state legislature and
a lot of republicans just stayed home
the republicans actually did better in
the suburbs in this particular election
than they did back in november but it
didn't matter because a lot of rural
white republicans did not show up all
the democrats showed up
the democratic turnout rates were over
90 percent
of what they were in november which is
unheard of for a special election the
republican turnout rates were closer to
87 or 88 percent
that was the entire difference in these
votes okay so
the campaign should have been stopped
joe biden and it wasn't stopped joe
biden
okay so what does that actually mean for
for the future of the country what is
that actually what comes next we'll get
to that in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that right now
there are a lot of people coming to your
door and you want to know who those
people are right for both safety and
security reasons and also because it's
just good to know what's happening on
your property
and maybe you're at the office maybe
you're on a business trip you still want
to know what is going on
at your house and that is why ring is an
excellent excellent device we've had
ring
devices on our house for for years and
as soon as we moved my wife said
we need to get more ring devices on the
new house that's literally the first
thing that we did
that's why now is the perfect time to
upgrade your doorstep with a ring
video doorbell with ring you can see and
speak to whoever is at the door from
anywhere right on your phone so you're
never going to miss a visitor whether
it's your neighbor
your dinner your groceries or you can
keep those packages
and delivery safe with motion detection
you'll get notified even if they don't
ring the doorbell if somebody stops by
or something is going on ring lets you
know this is really useful for me
because i have kids who are constantly
running out the front door
and i can hear that little ring device
chime and i now know that my kids are
running out the front door and i can go
and i can stop them
i love having the ring video doorbell
i've actually added some ring security
cameras around the house
as well i gotta keep track of the kids
right now get a special offer on the
ring welcome kit
at ring.com it comes with the ring video
doorbell 3 and the trim pro it's the
perfect way to upgrade your front door
and start that ring experience go to
ring.com once more that is ring.com
ben okay so what is going to happen next
so
right now basically the hopes of the
republic lie with joe manchin
the democratic senator from west
virginia the only reason that joe
manchin
is still in the senate in west virginia
is because
he is a very right-wing democrat meaning
he has institutionally allied himself
with left-wing members of the republican
caucus pretty often people like susan
collins and lisa murkowski
he also happens to be an
institutionalist in the in the mold of
john mccain which means
that he is anti getting rid of the
filibuster and he is anti-packing the
court here is joe
manchin not all that long ago saying
that he is not going to stand
in favor of killing the filibuster or
expanding the supreme court
i commit to you tonight and i commit to
all of your viewers and everyone else
that's watching
i want to lay those fears i'm going to
rest those fears for you right now
because when they talk about whether it
be
packing the courts or ending the
filibuster i will not vote to do that
i will not vote to pack the courts i
think and i will not vote to end the
filibuster
bret this system the senate was so
unique body in the world
it was made to work together in a
bipartisan way and once you start
breaking down those barriers
then you lose every every reason that we
are the institution that we are the most
deliberate body
okay so so watch for joe manchin to
absolutely be shellacked by the left i
mean
every day the pressure is going to be on
jump mansion because so many of the
democratic hopes for their legislative
priorities
rest in ramming through everything with
51 votes or 50 plus kamala harris
so if the filibuster is still in place
you need 60. to break the filibuster you
need 60 votes
so without killing the filibuster what
exactly can be done and this is
this is why realistically speaking biden
is not going to get most of his agenda
here so that's that's a comfort right
just on a legislative level that's a
comfort because what biden would wish to
ram through and what he is capable of
ramming through
are two very different things okay the
the process that he is going to use is a
process called
budget reconciliation okay budget
reconciliation is
there's a certain area of american law
and senate procedure in which 51 votes
or 50 plus the vice president to break a
tie that that number of votes
is necessary only in order to pass
particular budgetary items
so you can't for example pass amnesty
through budget reconciliation now
he may not have to pass amnesty through
budget reconciliation right he may
actually have the
votes for amnesty like this is the thing
that i'm most worried about on a pure
legislative level
there are really three things that i'm
worried about on a pure legislative
level
from joe biden with his new senate
majority which is just unthinkably bad
here are the three things i'm worried
significantly about tax increases
because of budget reconciliation which
i'll explain in a second
i'm worried about immigration because i
think there are a lot of soft-hearted
republicans
and uh and in some cases soft-headed
republicans who are going to try and
revive
the 2013 immigration deal that would not
only
legalize the so-called dreamers but
would actually legalize 11 million
people
minimum or in the country illegally
right create a quote-unquote pathway to
citizenship for them
and and get very little in return
because there are a lot of republicans
out there who still believe
that if they're soft on immigration
somehow this is going to shift latino
voters in
into their into their aisle i i don't
see the evidence for that at all donald
trump
actually outperformed with hispanics
compared to for example
mitt romney in 2012. romney was very
soft on immigration
or at least more soft on immigration
trump was very harsh on immigration and
very openly harsh on immigration and he
did much better in 2020 with hispanics
than he did in 2016. so the evidence
that republicans would be making a smart
electoral move by signing on to some
sort of giant amnesty bill that
legalizes
what is really not 11 million it's
probably closer to 20 million people who
are in the country illegally
that that seems like bad politics to me
but it doesn't
it would also not be hard i think to
peel off enough republicans to defeat a
filibuster there so
that is uh the top legislative priority
that is likely to receive some sort of
bipartisan negotiation for republicans
because republicans are afraid of the
issue even though they really should not
be
even though there actually is a pretty
wide consensus in the united states what
to do about immigration
which is make sure people don't come
into the country illegally if they do
come into the country illegally
then you deport them if they've been
here for a very long time then you
determine whether they ought to remain
in the country based on whether they are
of benefit to the united states or
whether they are not
right everybody basically agrees on that
by pulling data but republicans i think
might well sign on to some sort of
amnesty bill because they've done so in
the past
so i'm worried about tax increases i am
worried about immigration
and i'm worried about the public option
because democrats did use budget
reconciliation
to pass obamacare right they did use
this process they twisted this process
to use budget reconciliation okay so
what is budget reconciliation and it's
going to get a little obstructive but
it's important
you got to know these rules because
these are the rules democrats are going
to use
if mansion doesn't cave on the
filibuster now if mansion caves on the
filibuster it's all over right i mean
the country is basically toast if
mansion caves on the filibuster
and if the democrats get rid of the
filibuster in the senate
then they would move immediately to make
puerto rico and washington d.c
states which would add four senators
they would immediately move
to pack certain federal courts right
they would be able to ram through with
51 votes extraordinarily radical
legislation on everything from the
so-called green new deal
to the so-called equality act but
assuming that the that the filibuster
holds
then what they're going to be able to do
probably is amnesty
because again i'm not sure that
filibuster will even hold for amnesty uh
i think they'll be able to do tax
increases through budget reconciliation
and probably the public option okay so
what is budget reconciliation
so vox did a did a rundown of this and
this actually happens to be a fairly
decent rundown
talking about what budget reconciliation
is they did this back in 2019
reconciliation was designed to make sure
the united states senate could pass
easily
bills dealing with the federal budget
particularly if congress wanted to
reduce the deficit without the threat of
a filibuster from the minority party
the process begins with a congressional
resolution instructing committees in the
house and senate to draw up legislation
that saves the federal government a set
amount of money
so the special privileges under
reconciliation come with conditions
right the goal here was to have the
budget not be held up by filibuster
every single time
and so there is a rule that was created
that you could pass a budget with 51
votes but
certain conditions that needed to be met
a bill passed under budget
reconciliation is forbidden from
increasing the federal deficit outside
a 10-year window so you have to wait for
the cbo estimate
remember that republicans did this with
the with the trump tax cuts right they
passed that through budget
reconciliation
and then they waited for the cbo to say
that it wasn't going to raise the
deficit outside a 10-year window
there is also something known as the
byrd rule the rule came about in the
1980s
after west virginia senator robert byrd
grew frustrated with budget
reconciliation because
his colleagues were using it to advance
all sorts of stuff not just stuff
related to spending and revenue so
there's a new standard for what can be
included in a reconciliation bill
this has been enshrined in federal law
so it has to check all of these boxes in
order for you to be able to pass it with
50 votes plus
kamala harris breaking the tie every
time i say that it just makes me want to
spin my head around
like uh like the lady from the exorcist
and vomit everywhere just cover the
entire studio and vomit kamala here is
breaking ties in the senate unbelievable
un effing believable okay so here is
sorry sound engineers here is the um so
here is the the
bird rule okay these are the tests for
the bird rule one the provision must
change federal spending
revenue okay so it can't just be on an
unrelated topic like the equality act
which is about
regulating transgender bathrooms and
such two
if the bill does not meet the budget
resolution's instructions to reduce the
federal deficit
any provision that results in either
increased spending or decreased revenue
is removed until it does meet those
targets so
any budget that is passed under this is
supposed to be revenue neutral
right this is why you remember that they
totally game the system on this with
obamacare
so they came up with these bull crap
explanations of how obamacare was going
to be revenue neutral even though it
actually costs
the country over the years hundreds of
billions of dollars minimum
three the provision must only affect
policies that fall under the
jurisdiction
of the specific committees that were
instructed in the budget resolution
four the provision's effect on spending
a revenue must be more than incidental
to its policy impact so in other words
you can't say
yeah we did a bill on transgender
bathrooms and that has a budget impact
no it's got to be like the primary focus
of the bill it has to be very very
central to the bill five
the provision cannot increase the
federal deficit at some point in the
future beyond the typical 10-year budget
window that is used to evaluate
legislation
and six the provision cannot be used to
change social security right that was
enshrined to make sure that republicans
didn't use budget reconciliation
in order to shore up social security so
for healthcare bills number four is the
real problem
because again the healthcare bill could
be argued to really not be about the
budget at all
now democrats have usually gone to the
rulemakers in the house the senate
parliamentarian and said okay well you
know what it actually isn't incidental
and then rammed things through
it does create a problem for things like
medicare for all for example
it could be a problem for for the uh
for for the public option that joe biden
is attempting to push
it could also not be a problem for that
so
budget reconciliation is the way that
senate democrats are going to get things
done
that is going to take off the table
things like the green new deal that
radically raise the debt
radically raise it it's going to take
off the table things like the equality
act thank god because
the equality act is is really dangerous
it's
by the way again joe biden when it comes
to immigration reform
my concern is that republicans aren't
going to cave on immigration reform i
mean biden has said over and over and
over again he wants comprehensive
immigration reform here he was during
the campaign saying that
on day one i'm sending no matter what
the state of this is
to the united states congress a bill to
provide for a path to citizenship
for 11 million undocumented people
number one in the united states
number two every daca student will be
able to stay
it's a gigantic objective of mine
to see to it that we make a we have an
immigration system
that's consistent with our values and
who we say we are okay so he really
wants to push that right and we'll see
if republicans cave on it this is where
the republican base is going to need to
stand up on its legs and say no to its
own senators if those senators try
and ram through some sort of crappy
amnesty bill okay we're gonna get to
more of this in just
one second then we'll talk about the
real damage that a biden administration
is going to do because it really is not
going to be mainly
in the land of legislation though of
course it will be in the land of
legislation
as well first let's talk about your
sleep quality so i didn't sleep well
last night how'd you do
but here's the thing tonight i will be
very tired because i really slept poorly
last night
and i will be so relieved to be on my
helix sleep mattress because that
mattress was made
just for me helix sleep has a quiz it
takes just two minutes to complete
it matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else with helix you're getting a
mattress that you know
will be perfect for the way you sleep
everybody's unique helix knows that they
have several different mattress models
to choose from they've got soft medium
firm mattresses mattresses great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
folks it's been awesome getting unboxing
videos from so many of you who found the
helix sleep mattress of your dreams the
mattress is fantastic my wife and i took
the two-minute sleep quiz we got a
mattress made just for us and the thing
is just it's like sleeping on a cloud
it's great just go to helixsleep.com
take that two-minute sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that will give you
the best sleep of your life they've got
a 10-year warranty you get to try it out
for 100 nights risk-free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love
it but you absolutely will helix is
offering up to 200 bucks off all
mattress orders and
two free pillows before our listeners at
helixsleep.com again that's
helixsleep.comben
okay so the the main threat of the
biden administration is going to be as i
say through tax increases
it's going to be through but maybe using
budget reconciliation in order to ram
through a public option
a public option would be a disaster by
the way now i know a lot of people don't
understand what a public option is but a
public option is basically the federal
government
sets up an alternative to private health
care insurance and the idea is that they
are now going to subsidize health care
for everyone
right so there will be a baseline level
of health care provided by the federal
government you don't have to be poor to
access it right you don't have to be on
medicare or medicaid
in order to access this it would just be
people will get thrown off their
insurance willy-nilly because employers
are not going to want to pay for it
doctors are going to be forced to take
it by the federal government because
that's the only way to make a public
option work if doctors say i'm not
taking your crappy reimbursement rates
and hospitals say we're not going to
take your reimbursement rates
then you're either going to have to
prosecute them or you're going to have
to
tie a public option to medicare and
medicaid which would
bankrupt hospitals and doctors then
you subsidize these programs up to wazoo
you you
force all of the ancillary charges onto
the private companies and you bank up
the private companies
there's a reason that every democrat who
talks about the public option talks
about it knowing
that the eventual goal is the
destruction of the private health
insurance industry
right which is where you're getting your
good health care right now the vast
majority of americans are getting their
health care there
as heritage points out you first create
the illusion the government plan is less
expensive by shifting all the costs to
doctors hospitals
and other providers and then you keep
doctors and other providers from
rejecting low government payment rates
by coercing them into joining the new
government healthcare plan
and then you make the private
alternatives unaffordable and then you
bankrupt them
right that is the goal of the public
option joe biden is uh
is likely to push that extremely hard
we'll see if they can push that through
via the uh via the budget reconciliation
process
that depends now on the senate
parliamentarian before it would be a
foregone conclusion that would not go
anywhere because republicans would have
maintained in control of the senate but
they didn't
so now we're gonna have to rely on the
niceties of the senate parliamentarian
and joe manchin right that's what we're
going to have to rely upon and we'll see
how well that goes
i think that um i have doubts as to how
well that is going to go
but let's be real about this the real
the real problem with democrats having
unified control of the government is
going to be everything else
it's going to be everything else can be
executive action so
the senate was not an obstacle to
executive action in the first place but
having senators who are capable of
stopping broad-scale legislation
on a simple majority basis would have
stymied a lot of the
the executive action that joe biden
wanted to push at least on a rhetorical
level
most of what joe biden is going to do is
going to be an executive basis it's
going to be extraordinarily dangerous
what we're going to watch is going to be
an exacerbation of the culture wars this
is what's tearing apart the country
right now this is what folks need to
understand
what folks really need to understand is
that
what we have been watching over the past
several years is not really argument
over legislation
i know you watch shows like this when
you listen to shows like this one we
talk politics all day right we talk
about
the legislation that's going through
congress we talk about presidential
action
the reality is that yes politics is
downstream of culture meaning that the
vast majority of people vote based on
their feelings about politics without
actually knowing anything right polls
show this over and over and over again
it's what happened in georgia last night
people didn't know anything about
raphael warnock and so they voted for
raphael warnock
the only impression they had of kelly
lefler is that kelly leffler
was a rich lady who's out of touch with
the people
and that was because culture is
downstream uh that politics is
downstream from culture people had
perceptions
widespread perceptions about wealth in
america that are not true and systemic
american racism that are not true and so
they voted in line with those cultural
preconditioning sentiments created by an
overtly partisan media
and a hollywood structure and a
narrative structure that's been created
by nearly every institution around you
right that's that's that's how politics
is downstream from culture but politics
is also part of the culture and what
that means is that when you have
the federal government of the united
states constantly in every area
pressing forward the left the wild left
woke social agenda
it means that your personal daily life
is going to be impacted by this
so let's talk about that for a second
let's talk about the culture war
okay let's talk because that's that's
really why trump was made president in
the first place in 2016. it wasn't
because trump
said anything about legislation nobody
knew why the hell
like what trump even thought about
legislation moving up to the 2016
election
i had no idea whether he was going to
raise taxes or lower them i had no idea
whether he was going to try to defund
planned parenthood or refund planned
parenthood like he had said all of these
things it wasn't about that
it was that trump understood on a gut
level the frustration of many americans
with the culture war
those culture wars are going to be
exacerbated right now i think what we
are going to see right now
is democrats overreach not just in terms
of legislation
right here's the thing if democrats
overreach in terms of legislation
then the american system is
self-correcting barack obama over
overreached in terms of legislation in
his first couple of years with obamacare
and with the giant stimulus bills and
with cash for clunkers and with all this
other nonsense
and within two years the republicans had
swept back into power in the house
so if the democrats overreach in terms
of legislation then there will be a
blowback to that politically speaking
and again because the filibuster exists
you can't really overreach
in terms of legislation as much as
democrats would love to
right that that's that's not going to
happen where they really can overreach
and where it has long-lasting impact
even if there is blowback
is they can overreach in terms of the
culture that they push they can continue
to overreach
along the the lines of the canceled
culture and when you have the president
of the united states
who will be joe biden come the end of
january when you have him
continuing to push the obama line with
the full compliance of the senate
and the full compliance of the house and
the full compliance of the big tech
companies who are now deeply afraid
deeply afraid of bipartisan attempt to
shut down big tech
who are now scared crapless of joe biden
when you have all like if there had been
a republican senate and
mitch mcconnell was in charge the big
tech companies at least would feel
fear from mitch mcconnell right now they
don't fear feel fear for mitch mcconnell
they fear elizabeth warren and joe biden
what does that mean for what you get to
post on social media and what you get to
see on social media
if you're worried about big tech
predations right now what do you think
when all the members of the big tech
upper echelon are in
constant cahoots with people who have
unified control of american government
how do you think that's going to go
right if you're talking about
legislation that could get passed you
know a bipartisan attempt to crack down
on big tech in a way that does not
benefit conservatives
is highly likely at this point it's
going to impact
how you speak to your friends and your
family and barack obama
the real damage that barack obama did as
president of the united states
was not the legislative damage obamacare
sucked
the tax increases sucked the the
sequestration effect of
slashing the military was terrible all
that is reversible what he did to the
culture
is the long-lasting impact of barack
obama and it's going to exacerbate it's
going to get a lot worse
under joe biden with the with the echo
chamber of the media behind him with the
echo chamber of us of a democratic
senate behind him with the echo chamber
of a democratic house behind him
right that's the stuff that is truly
dangerous we'll get to that in just one
second first
let's talk about the fact that um you
know there are awkward things in life
to talk about unified democratic control
of government erectile dysfunction there
are many things that are awkward in life
but one of those things could be solved
right now all you would have to do is
head on over to roman with roman and get
a free online evaluation and ongoing
care for ed
all from the comfort and privacy of your
home a healthcare professional will work
with you to find the best treatment plan
if medication is appropriate
roman will ship you real medicine with
free two-day shipping the whole process
is straightforward simple and discreet
getting started is really easy
just go to getroman.com and complete an
online visit eg used to be tough to talk
about now there is roman
complete that online visit today connect
with the doctor get it taken care of
just go to getroman.com to get up to 50
bucks off your first month of edu
treatment a free online visit and
free two-day shipping that is
getroman.com
for up to 50 bucks off your first month
of ed treatment get roman.com
ben g-e-t-r-o-m-a-n.com ben if you have
a medical problem like edie there's no
reason why you should wait around on it
just go get it solved today and then you
don't have to think about it anymore
your life is better get roman.com
that's getroman.com for up to 50 bucks
off your first month
of ed treatment okay so as i say it's
the culture war where all this stuff is
going to happen
remember joe biden has has its foreign
policy and the culture war on executive
orders where most of the stuff is going
to happen but the culture war is what
impacts you personally run foreign
policy we already know what he's going
to do he's going to try and re-enter
the iran deal and try to wreck all of
these peace deals in the middle east
in fact over the last 48 hours biden
plan
says that he plans to name a bunch of
former obama administration officials to
senior jobs at the state department and
nsc
the national security council in the
coming days according to the washington
post
he's going to nominate wendy sherman the
chief u.s negotiator of the garbage iran
nuclear deal
and former number three at the state
department so so that's um
that's going to be horrible right he's
going to he's going to bring back in the
old team we knew all that
we also knew that he was going to redo
things
like the education agenda of betsy devos
right he's going to
reinstate a push for critical race
theory
in in public schools he is going to
reinstate
the awful awful title mind standards
that suggested kangaroo court for people
who are accused
of any sort of sexual misconduct on
college campuses
betsy devos actually wrote a farewell
letter to congress in which
she urged congress to keep supporting
school choice and to resist efforts by
the incoming biden administration to
make college free for some students
cancel some student debt
biden is being encouraged to do that
through unilateral action
so you know that that could happen but
again the real impact here is going to
be the cultural push
the cultural push remember the biden
sanders agendas remember that very early
on
in the in the race after biden had
obviously picked up the nomination
he created a unity agenda with bernie
sanders
by the way worth noting members of the
squad were points to the house oversight
committee so if you've enjoyed the house
oversight committee's shenanigans for
the past several years get ready for
more
and worse okay but in that agenda in
that biden sanders agenda
appeared in the following sentences
which are going to be the guiding
philosophy when it comes to race
and presumably all other quote unquote
anti-discrimination in american life
quote we need proactive
anti-discrimination detection and
enforcement
on day one we are committed to taking
anti-racist actions for equity across
our institutions
including in the areas of education
climate change criminal justice
immigration and health care
among others so what does that mean
that means that they are looking for
equal outcome among all racial groups
and all subgroups in the united states
the coalition of the victims of the
victimized
is going to be ascendant again under joe
biden and if you stand in their way
they're going to call you racist sexist
bigoted homophobic jerks he's going to
use the power of the federal government
unchecked by congress to ram through
investigations tax investigations of
churches that do not comply
with joe biden's perceptions of
anti-discrimination law watch for it
okay this is my prediction the irs will
be militarized on behalf of the woke
social agenda
tax plans are going to be increased
across the nation it's going to quash
the economic recovery now the good news
for joe biden
is all the stars are aligned for that
guy apparently the good news for joe
biden is that because we are in the
middle of a coveted pandemic the economy
is artificially depressed right now
that means that almost no matter what he
does the economy is still going to grow
throughout 2021
so he can raise taxes to exorbitant
levels the economy will still probably
grow it'll just grow a lot slower
than it would have under president trump
or under republican congress timing
those efforts
remember joe biden's tax plan would make
the tops inc the top income tax rate
in states like new york and california
62 percent
62 percent quashing industry crushing
investment
okay but because everybody's out of work
right now because of covid
and as the vaccines start to to move
through the american economy and people
start to go back to work and start to
participate in american life again
biden is going to be able to live off of
the off of the fumes of the trump
economy and
thanks to the natural bounce that occurs
after an artificial depression like
we've experienced over the past year
he's going to be able to claim that his
policies are actually not that bad
but i keep coming back to this point the
the biggest problem that you're going to
have is social it's the it's the problem
in your life it is the problem that
you're going to be having in your life
with your friends and family who are
going to be declaring you
even more so than this is not going to
decelerate with trump out of office
there are a lot of people out there who
seem to be under the impression that
with trump out of office their friends
and neighbors are going to treat them
well again
wrong you are democrats have complete
control of government
they're going to be using the control of
the press and the control of government
to pose their wokism as the new normal
and if you stand in the way
your corporation will fire you your
friends will disown you
right social life is going to become
more polarized not less now
trump at least provided a single point
of solidarity
for a lot of republicans who wanted to
unify in opposition to the cultural
agenda
now how do they do it now how do they do
it i'm going to get to some solutions in
a second to this because i don't think
all hope is lost in fact i think
that this might be the the kick in the
pants
i i hope the silver lining part of me
hopes that this is the kick in the pants
republicans need to actually stop
with the nonsense and do the hard on the
ground work
of reconstructing a system in order to
win broad victories
but here's where this is going okay
there's alexis de tocqueville writing in
about what happens in democracies when
cultural despotism occurs
he says the master no longer says you
shall think as i do or you shall die he
says
you're free not to think as i do your
life your goods everything remains to
you
but from this thing on you're a stranger
among us you shall keep your privileges
in the city but they will become useless
to you for if you crave the vote of your
fellow citizens they will not grant it
to you
if you demand only their esteem they
will still pretend to refuse it to you
you shall remain among men but you shall
lose your rights of humanity when you
approach those like you they shall flee
you as being impure and those who
believe in your innocence even they
shall abandon you for one would flee
them in their turn
go in peace i leave you your life but i
leave it to you worse than death right
that is going to be
the culture of the united states that's
going to be the culture of the united
states under a unified
democratic-controlled government
so what can be done to fight this what
can be done what can be done
to turn back this tidal wave that is
coming for you
and coming for your family and coming
for your church we'll talk about that in
just
one second because i do think that there
is hope maybe
maybe this is the the kick in the pants
conservatives need to get it together
and start acting in solidarity
now with regard to particular
legislation or particular politicians
but with regard to each other
it is more important that the social
fabric that binds not just conservatives
but all americans who believe in freedom
of speech and freedom of association
grow i don't care all that much about
which politicians are elected
as long as they leave me alone but i i
care about politics because they won't
leave you alone
i'm much more concerned i'm not
concerned about your loyalty to a
particular politician because
politicians are not loyal to you they're
loyal to themselves
invariable truth of life but i am
concerned about the loyalty we have to
one another
about the horizontal social fabric of
the united states we need to form
social ties that help prevent the
predations of a top-down federal
government
and their woke allies in the media in
the corporate world
and in and in hollywood and in the
scientific community the tsunami is
coming
we better build a dam right now okay
like right now we'll get to that in just
one second first
our eyes were not meant to look at
screens all day and i will tell you like
months and months ago before i had felix
gray glasses
i'd get headaches at night because i
stare at screens all day long right i
mean i look at my computer screen and
then i'm looking at my phone screen and
then i'm watching tv with my wife at
night
and spend hours and hours in front of a
screen all day god didn't mean your eyes
for that so that's why your eyes
probably hurt at the end of the day it's
probably why you have a headache
you need felix gray glasses they filter
15 times more blue light from screens
than any other
clear blue light lenses to help restore
your balance the original optical lenses
relieve
most eye strain symptoms from daily
screen time the more advanced sleep
glasses relieve serious daily eye strain
were especially designed for late night
screen time to improve sleep
felix gray frames their hand finished
from italian acetate making them durable
lightweight super comfortable
blue light lenses come standard starting
at 95 bucks or you can add your
prescription at checkout starting
at 145 bucks it's not going to cost you
a fortune to get rid of the headaches
you've been suffering because of the
blue light and if you don't love the
glasses in the first 30 days
their in-house customer care team will
take care of exchanges and returns no
hassle
no questions asked felix gray glasses
are designed for the 21st century go to
felix grayglasses.com
ben to shop glasses that work as hard as
you do that is f e l i x g
r ay glasses dot com slash ben free
shipping free exchanges 30 day money
back guarantee
felix grayglasses.com ben
okay we're gonna get to more of this in
just one second first
there's a reason that millions and
millions of americans believe overt lies
about the state of of politics about
their fellow americans about
conservatives
and a lot of that has to do with the
culture war that we're talking about
right now
if we don't fight the culture or if we
don't get involved in the culture where
we're going to lose daily wear is
joining the culture war
that is why we are launching our first
mainstream motion picture run hide fight
it's not kind of a typical conservative
film with an altar call at the end
or or with a sort of happy church
message that that's not what the movie's
about
okay the movie is intense it is violent
it is rated r it is edgy and it is
designed
to draw younger americans particularly
to
more conservative values the movie
follows a high school besieged by a
quartet of school shooters when one
young girl 17 year old zoe hull
uses her wits and survival skills to
fight back you can watch the full
trailer over at the daily wire
youtube channel it's fantastic the
performances are really good it is high
quality movie making
really i mean it it's the first time
anybody in the conservative world has
done anything like this
go check it out right now by going to
dailywire.com because run height fight
will be available to watch friday
january 15th if you're a subscriber at
dailywire.com
we'll be doing a special live stream
premiere the night before on thursday
january 14th
on the daily wire youtube channel let's
kick off 2021 by fighting back
in the culture we need to create our own
content we need alternatives that's what
we're trying to be
for you we want to replace the media
that lie to you and lie about you on a
daily basis check us out at
dailywear.com you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
okay so when i say that we're gonna have
to fight back in the culture i'm saying
that because there are a lot of people
who are putting
a lot of stake in what happens in the
senate today as though the senate is
going to challenge electoral votes and
then suddenly trump is going to retain
the presidency that's not going to
happen
i mean i don't wish to be the bearer of
bad tidings i wish i
god i wish it were not this way okay but
that there is no legal process
to do what people want pence or the
senate republicans to do they're just
not
okay i explained the law in detail on
monday that's not how any of this works
okay you're allowed to challenge
electoral votes when there's more than
one slate of electors legally sent by a
particular state
when there's actual fraud and voter
irregularity that has been proved
you're not allowed to simply challenge
votes because you don't like the outcome
of votes in particular states and it is
not a forum
to talk about voter processes within
states the federal government was not
given charge of this
the whole point of the electoral college
is that states are supposed to have
the final say in who gets elected
president of the united states
that is the purpose of the electoral
college to put the federal congress
over that is to essentially grant i mean
on
on a on a moral basis it's wrong but
beyond that
on a political level it's absolutely
asinine for republicans to want that
kind of standard going forward
if republicans want the federal congress
or the national popular vote
deciding this thing republicans have won
one national popular vote
in the presidential election since i was
four years old it was in 2004 and that
was after 9 11
and after an election in which george w
bush lost the popular vote by half a
million
in 2000. okay so the electoral college
if you want republicans to win in the
future
you need to preserve the electoral
college you don't want to destroy its
legitimacy
you don't want to suggest that the
federal congress can simply throw out
votes that you don't like
and you certainly don't want to suggest
that the vice president has the
unilateral power
to simply disregard certified electoral
college votes there is no precedent for
this in the 12th amendment there is no
legal basis for it
even under the 12th amendment it just
says that pence can open the votes
it doesn't say that he gets stick even
count them it says the votes shall be
counted
under the twelfth amendment so people
who are saying today that
the senate republicans are going to
change the outcome of the josh halley
knows they are not he has admitted as
much
ted cruz knows they are not everybody
knows this
okay so all this is is right now is just
a show of upset over the election or a
show of field to
trump but it is not intended to actually
change the outcome
okay that is the the baseline truth it
is not going to change a thing and that
is not
because of republican cuckishness or
because of republican cowardice it's
because there's a system of laws and
rules in this country
they are embedded in the law andy
mccarthy a huge trump fan a huge trump
advocate
has written extensively about this
anybody who's suggesting that mike pence
is the guy who will just reinstall like
how do you think this is going to go
how would i have gone in 2016 if joe
biden had simply said you know what
hillary clinton won by three and a half
million popular votes
and you know it appears that trump beat
her in wisconsin michigan and
pennsylvania but it was such a slim
margin you know i i don't really like
those votes so we're just gonna
i unilaterally joe biden i've decided
i'm not going to count any of those
votes
unless hillary clinton becomes president
how do you think that you would feel
about that
okay well if you don't like that idea
then you probably shouldn't like the
ideas that are now being proposed
now president trump is still tweeting
out their things suggesting that
vice president pence knows he can
overturn the election he put out a
statement suggesting
that he has several options under the
constitution he can decertify the
results he cannot
this is not legal he can send them back
to the states for change and
certification
he cannot he can also decertify the
illegal and corrupt results and send
them to the house of representatives for
the one vote for one state tabulation no
he cannot he does not have that power
under the constitution of the united
states
okay that's not what's going to happen
today okay so
the the trumpian solution here is not
the solution and by the way
it is worthy of note that this entire
last two months
did have an impact into extraordinarily
close prices in georgia
and probably turning those democrats hey
there there are several
key mistakes that were made throughout
the past two months on this particular
issue
and other related issues that probably
destroyed the ability of republicans to
hold the senate and that is not an uh
that is not an excuse
for david perdue who's not a
particularly wonderful candidate or
kelly lefler who's a very not
wonderful candidate but the reality is
that in georgia
in an off-year election in a special
election in which republicans had every
reason to go out and show up at the
polls
and democrats really did not have
tremendous reason to show up at the
polls democrats showed up at the polls
more often than republicans did in
broader numbers
and that is for several reasons here's
the incentive structure i promised i was
going to analyze what actually happened
in georgia last night so here is the
actual analysis of what happened in
georgia last night
republicans one month ago in the polls
were up a little bit
by the time of the election they were
down a little bit okay they were
within margin of error but it was it was
close democrats had an advantage
okay then the republicans passed in the
house and in the senate in late december
a coveted relief package and david
perdue began running ads on it and kelly
leflar began running ads on it and these
ads were good ads because these ads were
designed to show the democrats had
obstructed covert relief in the middle
of a pandemic
for political purposes right that was
the ad and then
donald trump decided in a fit of peak
that he was going to reject the coveted
relief bill and call for a two thousand
dollar check
to be put out to everybody okay which
meant
that now john ossoff and raphael warnock
could claim that the actual
obstructionist
were all of the republicans who had just
voted for a coveted relief bill that the
democrats had stymied for six months
and that was the democrats who were
truly generous i mean joe biden the day
before the election said
if you give me these senators you will
get a 2 000 check in the mail
you know who created the groundwork for
that that was donald trump because chuck
schumer embraced it and so did nancy
pelosi
and you can blame purdue and lefler for
not getting on board with the 2 000
check idea but that wouldn't have even
been out there because the bill was
passed and done
okay so that was a mistake other
mistakes that occurred
when the president of the united states
doesn't matter how often he goes down
and he rallies in these areas
when those rallies circulate around the
idea that the georgia election was
fraudulent in november
and he provided no hard proof that the
georgia election was fraudulent november
when you do that over and over and over
when you run ads in the week of the
election suggesting
that brad raffensberger and brian kemp
and all the republicans in the state
legislature and all of those republicans
are basically bought off or basically
corrupt or screwing this thing up or
that you were schmucked to support them
do you think that the people who love
trump are really going to are going to
go out and vote in mass numbers
for david perdue and kelly lefler or are
they going to do what lynn wood was
telling them to do
are they going to stay home right
because here and not only that
when donald trump made himself the
center of the georgia senate races
after the election right i mean he's on
his way out because the electoral
college is already voted by the time of
the election
when trump made himself the center of
the election what did he do
he drove every democrat to the polls so
here's the thing about trump and it was
true in november
he drives a lot of republicans to the
polls he also drives a ton
of democrats to the polls particularly
democrats in urban areas
black democrats showed up in mass
numbers for warnock and ossoff
you know who didn't show up exactly the
people that donald trump is supposed to
appeal to the most
rural white voters in fact if rural
white voters had showed up in the same
numbers
this time around as they did back in the
beginning of november
then the republicans would have held not
only that republicans have been bleeding
out in the suburbs for years right i
mean if you look at the actual district
where ossoff did well this time those
were districts won by david perdue
in 2014. there's as much of a 20 to 30
point swing
in some of these districts in some of
these counties
over the last six years that has to do
with the fact that republicans basically
between 2012 and 2020
traded away a lot of their suburban
support in favor of role
of rural support here's the thing you
can have both
you can have both suburban support and
rural support it is not impossible to
have both
hey but by making himself to center
democrats showed up and every day
warnock warnock and assaf did not even
campaign really against purdue and
leffler they campaigned against trump
because trump was on the tv every single
day talking about how he was going to
shift the election
and how georgia had been screwed up and
warnock and leffler
and warnock and assaf were on tv every
day saying donald trump wants to
disenfranchise you
right which is not true doesn't matter
they got to play with that talking point
and democrats are willing to parrot it
that donald trump wants to
disenfranchise you if you're a democrat
he's a racist he wants to disenfranchise
you black voters showed up to the polls
in droves meanwhile
trump depressed his own vote in georgia
for those georgia senators
so the the the hope that donald trump
would retain the
and beyond that finally when donald
trump maintained over and over as he is
maintaining today by the way
that he will still be in office in
january 21st it said to a lot of
republicans okay well i want to punish
the georgia republican party for not
standing with donald trump
and i have faith that donald trump is
not lying to me and that on january 21st
he will still be president and so it
doesn't matter what i do with the senate
those senate republicans are cucks and
those senate republicans don't deserve
my support donald trump deserves my
support
and so i'm not going to bother voting
now that doesn't have to be a mass
number of people here's the thing in
georgia
the turnout for republicans was still
really really high right it was still
close to 90 percent
all it had to be was about three
percentage points more and the
republicans retain the senate
okay so we're not talking about every
trump supporter in georgia we're not
even talking about every republican
we're not talking about even a large
number
of people but the margins of these
victories are extraordinarily small
right john ossoff is up over over david
perdue
by something like 13 000 votes 14 000
votes right warnock is going to beat
leflore by maybe 40 or 50 000 votes
so what does this say this says a few
things one
republicans need to do the hard on the
ground work that democrats have been
doing for years they need to go precinct
to precincts they need to be registering
voters
they need to be making sure that their
voter networks are updated they need to
be doing
the kind of robocalls the democrats have
been doing repeatedly
and yes republicans in state
legislatures need to change the rules
when it comes to voting
early voting is a disaster area it is
morally wrong
okay early voting on mass early voting
is morally wrong
not because it's wrong to vote early on
an individual level but because when you
have
tons of people who are voting three four
weeks before an election a lot of stuff
happens
in those three to four weeks election
day is known as election day because it
is
election day now if you have a health
problem if you have a legit reason why
you can't vote
that day that's one thing but the notion
that anybody
for any reason should be voting two
months in advance of an election is
really it's ridiculous it's ridiculous
republicans need to show that they need
to show up voted or id they need to
cleanse the voter rules
they need to make sure that the system
is not being gamed that is hard on the
ground work that has to be done within
states it can't be done
by the senate today it can't be done by
congressional republicans who now have
no power
it can't be done by any of those people
it has to be done in the states hard
on the ground work hard on the ground
work that's what it's going to take
and in the meantime there's going to
need to be another thing that is done
and that is we need a cultural
solidarity movement between
conservatives
and classical liberals and people who
still love basic freedoms in the united
states
that's the biggest point that's the
biggest point we're going to need
a cultural solidarity movement i want to
talk about that for just one second
okay we are going to need a movement
where
people support one another where when
somebody
gets fired conservatives rehire the
person where
when one person sounds off inside a
company a thousand people sound off
inside the company
folks on the left are excellent at this
sort of cultural solidarity it's why you
see
folks unionizing over at alphabet the
google company i'm not calling for
conservatives to unionize
i'm saying that conservatives need to
say to their employers that
if you start firing people based on
their political point of view we will
all walk out
that we are not going to tolerate being
forced to parrot the woke memory
of our employers that if we're in
college and the college administrators
decide to go after conservatives or they
decide to put in place
bad administrative features that we're
going to go to the donors and we're
going to remove our money from the
system
republicans need to get it together
democrats have acted with solidarity and
they've used that solidarity to cram
down
their particular agenda conservatives
need to build alternative sources of
information
they need alternative sources of
entertainment they need to do what the
left has been doing
because the right believes in the power
of markets because the right beliefs and
the power of individuals we don't think
institutionally
okay and that has its benefits and it
has its drawbacks its benefit is that we
do think individually which is good
the drawback however is that because we
think individually and not
institutionally
we do not build institutions democrats
build institutions you want to know
why america has moved consistently to
the left since the 1960s
it's because one by one the left the
radical left increasingly has taken over
nearly every institution in american
life
forced it to the left and forced
everybody else to shut up they've
engaged in a renormalization effort
that has succeeded here's the thing
renormalization can be pursued in
reverse
you can renormalize an organization by
demonstrating intransigence when your
rights are violated
you have to do with your friends you
have to get together with other people
you have to make the connections and you
have to stand up as one it's not enough
to have one person
stand up and get fired it's not enough
to have one person standing
in the in the even even a politician
even president trump it's not enough to
have one person standing in the river of
culture and holding up his hand and
saying no
we all have to do it together we all
have to do it together and that's what
we're going to be working on at daily
wire i think that's what we all have to
work on
as americans as conservatives because a
lot of these principles are not just
conservative they're just basic american
principles
and that's what's going to be under us
all your freedom of religion your
freedom of association your freedom of
speech
that's what's coming get ready the
battle is on all right we're going to be
back here later today with an additional
hour of the ben shapiro show in the
meantime
go check out the michael moles show that
is available right now a little bit
later today we'll talk about the
jacob blake case where again the media
just have done extraordinary
disservice to the truth and to decency
we'll get to that a little bit later
today so stick around for that otherwise
we'll see you here tomorrow i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowski our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez
the show is edited by adam's high events
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021.
georgia determines control of the senate
republicans on capitol hill try to stop
certification of the presidential vote
and a shocking new report says men in
dresses still beat women at sports
check it out on the michael knowles show